[Music]
thank you
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good middle of the night we're
heavily on the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and this week I am with Paris
over here and howdy we have a special
treat house it's it's Christmas it's a
Christmas miracle it's our Christmas
present to all our fans but of course
back foreign
good to be back
Standing Ovation
Merry Christmas oh yeah Standing Ovation
oh yes thank you
Merry Christmas to everybody that's your
presentation you're not getting any
socks or anything
um of course just stormy Bears back
before we get stuck into it guys how the
hell are you both
I'm awake
you have been working your ass officer
and um we appreciate you giving us an
hour of your time building spaceships
and you thought who thought building
spaceships would be it would be
difficult I thought it'd be peace
business
yeah time consuming what yeah it's a bit
on the uh
labor side the complicated stuff I've
got big rocket pointed upwards how hard
can it be okay
all right guys so I mean before we start
talking about what we're looking forward
to for Christmas we'll do the norm thing
what what we've been watching guys what
we've been doing
anything
well for me uh in the last since I've
had off for Thanksgiving
um
I started watching I think it's season
10 of 24 which is not really sci-fi but
it was in Britain and they were blowing
the [ __ ] up out of London so there that
was something
I did binge the entirety of Wednesday
excellent
okay good it is like a really witchy
version of Nancy Drew
and I suggest everybody should see it it
was it was astoundingly good
so it's available here yet really
I'll try to find it what channel is it
on over there uh Netflix on Netflix yeah
you should go Netflix
it should be my friend that I was with
in Italy last week she's already binged
the whole thing too she said it was
really well done yeah well I need to
look at it then well unfortunately at
the moment I keep having to watch things
like I'm a celebrity get me out of here
and things like this because that's what
everyone else is watching so I started
to sit there going
around yeah
um how about you that's what have you
enjoyed this week sir
well I'm still kind of on travel mode so
I haven't been at a theater as much as I
should be but I have been catching up
with Stargate I'm halfway I think I'm on
episode 14 of season eight of sg1 and
episode 14 of Atlantis as well so I'm
stargating it up of course but my dad
and I went to go see the menu yesterday
or two days ago now in the theater and
that was
is it comedy but it gets a bit slashery
is that right
it's Thriller with a situational not
situational comedy that's not the right
way to do it it's a it's kind of witty
comedy in a way but it's it's really not
comedy but you will laugh if that makes
sense it's more of a thriller
suspenseful Thriller
very good I really enjoyed the Andor
finale and it does feel like it's the
end of all the Sci-Fi we've had so much
sci-fi to talk about in the last few
months and now it's like
the last but one episode was the was the
best episode but it was a it was a good
finale we got some stormtroops
step with him it was it was so good I
loved that whole whole episode A lot of
people are still there's a couple of
guys I follow uh YouTubers that I follow
and once Steve it did not like
um and or at all it's just too slow too
boring and I think no you're missing the
point it's supposed to be procedural and
a bit sort of like getting into the
detail of things that's kind of the
point of it I love it
and we've got to see the sort of a bit
of a background to the what did you guys
think of the finale I finished up and or
as well this uh Thanksgiving season and
it was I thought
um I thought of sex I mean I thought it
was really really good it was it told a
different type of story it wasn't I mean
there was action to it but it was more
like you said a police procedure
although it was a fascist police
procedural it was still a procedural
altogether
um I'm really excited to see where
season two goes a co-worker of mine was
just hating on him never seen an episode
oh that's not what Star Wars is Star
Wars is a movie it ain't no damn serious
what the hell you know and it was just
like dude you should go I ain't watching
it it's a TV series that ain't Star Wars
so it's like I think I think we're
getting into Commando huh yeah I mean
yeah he hasn't seen Mando for sure
you know I think I think with the Andor
we're reaching uh maximum trollishness
you know I mean everyone was hating on
it to begin with and
um
the the people that continue to hate on
it are can I be controversial here
they're just they're just absolutely
train wrecks stupid
foreign
they've decided they're not gonna like
that
never mind made
like at least wait for it to be
announced and then start
yeah
but and or pound per pound very well
might be my favorite Star Wars
Series so far
the animation may be withholding because
I I just love all the animation so much
especially the Star Wars Rebels separate
the two
um it's so well done no I think Mando
for me Mandalorian for me
um the second series maybe not the first
series the second series Mandalorian I
thought was excellent Boba Fett was good
in bits
but it was sort of like a bit of a
roller coaster Boba Fett but yeah
um I'm not sure on that one because
pound per pound maybe I still like
Mandalorian probably overall more but
pound per pound and I I just and or it's
just so well it's meticulous and that's
what I like that's that's a good word
for it is absolutely meticulous I mean
they put that if you want something Star
Wars and you're talking about
um you want somebody that loves
you know look the project
the guys that make this show love the
you know love Star Wars and love what
they're doing don't they then they know
the story backwards so that's
fascinating but and then they're Geeks
complete nudes which I love as well so
um the other thing I finally got around
to watching is Star Trek Prodigy and
again
Harris has no freaking clue look at that
surprise
um it's it's just I absolutely love it
and I love at the moment it's really
getting stuck in to
um it's sort of like a build up to
Picard series one and we're talking
about a lot of it is about the Romulan
Supernova is about to golf and I'm like
I just love a little this backstory and
yeah exactly a lot of you too I'm really
looking forward to the second season it
was really good yeah I'm just watching
the second season of Prodigy now I just
[ __ ] love it I think it's great I
love the detail again and it's um you
know a language I love lower decks but
the Prodigy is a bit more serious I just
love how they brought all these actors
back and then give us a bit of
background and fixings card so I'm just
like great
but I was watching a little bit of lower
decks this week also and I could swear I
saw Jeffrey combs's uh
his credits in the CR his name in
credits as a different character
of course he was a different character I
mean
I mean he's got I know he's got to hold
the record right for I think he's five
assistant how many characters did
Jeffrey Coombs actually play and the and
the blow come the thing says well it
depends how many Wayans you're counting
yeah points so it's either like five or
six or like 15 or 16 or something if
like if you count the different wines so
because what he did Harris he was um it
was in that they genetically engineered
certain people certain positions there
was multiple Wayans so he would die and
then he would just have like number six
way number seven would so it was just a
completely different one just for
character
so um but it was ridiculous but yeah of
course he was a completely different
character for another thing because he's
that's what he doesn't the thing is I
didn't recognize his voice
because he's such a good actor he is I
swear to God man he is top-notch if you
look at him as the uh obviously the
Wayne character and then you look at his
Ferengi character you would not believe
it's the same actor and I would think
that's a really good sign of a brilliant
actor I remembered like Dusty Dustin
Hoffman in like Tootsie or or hook you
wouldn't believe it's the same active
because he does such a good job you know
um
your assignment it disappears in the
role rolls yeah he was agamas AGI in U.S
Agonist I didn't know he was in The
Frighteners with uh our friend Peter
Jackson I did not know who was in the
frightness I love that movie that isn't
it underrated Michael Jack Michael J fox
movie Mrs Michael Jackson movie that was
unfortunate
your internet is awful
is it mine right never mind Paris where
are you today are you did you ever find
a bar in Rome that you were looking for
history's around every corner you're
just looking for a bar we all know it
but so did you find a couple okay
you did so we were all but now I'm back
in Texas
of course for a little bit yeah
so Texas that's the town I want to get
drunk in one day not too drunk because I
don't want to get [ __ ] in the face but
drunk I bet it's a good City to get
drunk uh right but that's that's not why
we're here today today we wanted to come
and have a little bit of a chat about
what we're looking forward to I mean a
couple of weeks ago we talked about what
we've enjoyed so far in 2022. now we're
going to look forward to the Christmas
period the festive season and look at
you know what we're looking forward to
and I gotta admit looking at you know
what's coming up on a lot of streaming
services it's a little bit Slim Pickens
I'm struggling a little bit to tell you
more than a handful of things I'm
actually looking forward to watching
um how has gone on with storms and I got
no idea and my internet's bad yeah my
favorite stand is all screwed up so
anyway I apologize yeah for the only
thing that I think that we've got coming
up for sci-fi
has got to be Avatar 2 wave water yeah
it's got to be it I mean you know I
don't I think everybody the other sci-fi
fantasy creators don't want to put
anything out
during the next during this because
Avatar
I mean if we if we uh use the first uh
filter as a as a a barometer
the second one's going to just kick ass
I mean you know if we look at like alien
in the movie Aliens
um camera and he really amped it up I
mean usually the sequels suck not with
James Cameron he finds a way to pick up
the story and engage the audiences and
he did that I mean
uh he's just gifted you know when it
comes to filmmaking when you're like
three or four guys that's really good at
that you know that I mean are really
Geniuses in terms of filmmaking these
days and he's probably top of the class
Cameron that he is such a good filmmaker
because you actually look at how many
films he's made and it's less than you
think no it's hardly anything yeah it's
that's because it puts everything into a
project when he does it
[Laughter]
we got no idea what's going on with my
setup the my computer rebooted itself
overnight and I just booted straight
into the uh let me boot back let me
reboot and come back in okay is that
cool if you like it all right yeah yeah
throw me back
my all my functions are
oh God what's going on
is
is and forever always will be
one of the top five filmmakers I I just
don't see how he can ever be discredited
from that maybe one day but that'd have
to be far far into the future because
he's that good
what do you think about his statement
though the um in the week that he said
this film has got to make two billion
dollars at the box office to break even
do you think that's a bit of a concern
I I think that's a bit of hyperbole I
don't know I don't think this film
particularly has to do 2 billion
although it would be awesome and great
for them and the studios involved Etc
but they have three four and five to
come out as well if they all hit a
billion I think they'll hit their mark
because I know they're all expensive but
they're kind of
turn them out of this hey I have a
budget of 270 million back in 2017 when
it first
it was was announced that it was going
to happen
but then obviously there's been so many
delays and
you know they he was actually asked in
the interview how much of this film
actually make to cut you know cost to
make and he just went a [ __ ] ton
hey
weren't
massively over budget
um and that's a concern because I mean
the highest grossing movie post covid is
top gun Maverick and that took 1.5
billion not quite nearly 1.5 billion
so if he's if he's not being
yeah oh yeah but if he's not joking and
this film has got to hit 2 billion or it
doesn't or it loses money
and they're in trouble
he did say that they could close out
with the third one instead of the fifth
one if they don't make enough money
but I I just can't bet against James
Cameron I I no that that's the kind of
whatever I think at the end of the day
is
I just can't bet against James Cameron
because I'd love for it to hit 2 billion
but I I almost feel like he said that
just to get people in seats in a way at
the same time of course you know that's
his kind of job at the moment to market
the movie but
he's not doing a bad job
I don't think I've ever heard a Movie
Maker say that before a film comes out
actually talking about how much money it
has to take to be a success that's I
think that's a risky strategy
I mean this film could be a massive
success I mean look how much of his
success topical Maverick was a huge
success top um Tom Cruise's highest
grossing movie of all time
um
but if it if it doesn't at least match
that it actually have to this film has
to exceed that or it loses money so it
could be a massive commercial success
by 500 million dollars yeah oh yeah by
500. that's it that's another quarter on
it another third that's that's probably
more than Black Adam or make in its
entirety of its run
uh that's kind of nearly made a billion
but not quite didn't it wasn't it 800
million I think it made
so um
if he's talking about this film cost two
billion dollars to make I I don't
believe him for start I don't think he
did
um but I know there's massive overings
but I mean could this film have cost a
billion dollars to make
oh oh yeah I mean but what both of the
Avengers movies uh infinity war and end
game together was 1.1 billion before
marketing so
and it can cost a hundred million
dollars to Market a movie nowadays all
right I was about to say I mean they
haven't really really really been
marketing like super hardcore because
word of mouth is obviously what Avatar
does best and better than anybody before
but
it ain't cheap
stormy is back
um
what I was going to say was that
um
I think this film if if it did cost a
billion dollars to make which is would
be ridiculous but if it did and and
covid and everything would have been a
big part of that
um I don't believe it cost two billion
dollars to make I just don't but if it
did I I think the highest grossing the
highest loss of movies ever made is like
Cutthroat Island or something like that
there's about 200 million dollars is the
most a film is ever lost
this film could lose 500 million dollars
easily and it will be considered a
partial success at least but the big
problem is
there's no DVD sales to sort of like try
to make up any of the difference
so I mean also I remember looking at
Kevin Smith his movies always used to
bomb at the cinema they never they would
maybe be making the money back
um one or two of his films were
commercial successes but the rest of the
results they would just about make the
money back but it says but at Miramax
they didn't care because his DVD sales
were so good they'd make that again
um so he they kept letting him make
films
um yeah they probably shouldn't have
done but they did
um you know and like there's no DVD
sales for this this it is what it takes
for the box office
that's it
and and that's just the hope Disney
because Disney and fox are Disney and
fox compared to Paramount and Top Gun
because Paramount was very happy to let
Top Gun stay in theaters and and not try
to go on streaming
I don't know if Disney and I mean Fox
but it's just Disney at this point I
don't know if Disney's gonna be that
willing they want to get things off 60
90 days after it's in a theater as
quickly as possible typically
they're going to want you on Spring can
in Spring and then to Mexico
yeah I don't know I don't know how long
James Cameron can convince them to keep
it in a theater it's going to depend on
the word of mouth but that's what Avatar
does best right so
fingers crossed two questions should it
have been released in the summer
foreign
with the things that we got this past
summer because Top Gun was prior to
Summer that was March so really the only
thing I could think of off the top of my
head that was a big movie this summer
is the first I mean I I there's I'm sure
there's more but Thor 11 Thunder's the
only thing that I can really think of
off the top of my head and that wasn't
all that big yeah I would have much
rather had Avatar at that point
I I hope that the holiday season ended
up being cold and people kind of being
stuck inside for a good portion of right
now will make people want to go out and
do something
um
but that's that's also a big hope and I
know that's Disney's in the hope as well
and James Cameron's hope but
people got to go and put their asses in
a seat you know and you gotta hope for
that point
what do you think stormy but it works
better as a summer blockbuster
what was that
would Avatar of work better as a summer
blockbuster rather than releasing it at
Christmas
yeah I oh God I really don't know it's
um
all right
I I think you know because if we're
still talking about like Avatar uh
coming out I think it's there's a lot of
people not just uh
you know the sci-fi fantasy genre but I
think a lot of films have just put it
off to like eat put their releases off
until Easter while all this dies down
because here you know at the multiplex
especially centuries Cinemark it's going
to be on you know 10 screens and that's
just one theater yeah you know I mean
it's no room for anything else because
you know the theaters are ordering up
all the screens that they can get it's
going to be a phenomenal first weekend I
mean if anything
it could break records I mean even not
not just post code records it could
break just full stop break records
I I wonder how much actually released in
the first avatar a month or six weeks
ago so however long it was it will have
helped this though because I mean you
talk about marketing they are the genius
marketing they just re-released the
original
oh I and I went to see it in a heartbeat
it's great yep
um right so a scale of one to ten then
how excited about Avatar wave water I
uh 10B
you lose your mind
let me let me uh let me drop back out
you guys are so staticky there's really
something wrong with my system I'll I'll
I will be back it
do you know I'm going to say something
very controversial though about Avatar
I'm a bit in there
I don't really care
I didn't love
the first one
not perfect not to the degree
at the other people I enjoyed it
I I would say it's an 8 out of ten movie
Easy oh yeah but a lot of other people
seem to think it was a 10 out of 10 the
most perfect movie ever made and I'm
like yeah
and I watched the advert I'm like it
just looks like the first one but wetter
it doesn't matter the storyline looks
the same to me they're they're like oh
with nature oh they're coming with their
tanks
oh you and then what seems to be the
story I mean I would go watch it and
then I'm sure it'll surprise me but it
looks like it might be the same story
um just some Concepts that are already
introduced in the trailer like Grace
essentially becoming obviously it's not
Grace from the first movie but Sigourney
Weaver's playing the child which is
going to have some type of
I mean just knowing James Cameron he
could literally do a whole thing like
about
Resurrection through that not just
Resurrection but I guess that was more
of the first thing he might be trying to
do uh cyclical rebirth and you know he's
kind of tackling some kind of big
conceptual ideas there will be some kind
of constructural ideas
and he's he's
something with that and yeah I don't
think the first film is perfect I think
it's groundbreaking and the story I mean
it's Fern Gully in space is what people
love to say and it's that's not false
you know and Billy's on the list of
movies that lost a crapload of money so
I mean he did look in there I I was just
for me it's a little bit too slow in
places
um it takes a while to get to the point
and
unobtaining I mean [ __ ] sake come on
you could do better than that how about
the best name but the the technology
behind it all is just pivotal for the
film industry and I I think
if everybody that just goes and sees
films just for the sake of just being
lovers of films goes and watches it and
then goes and tells their friends to
watch it hopefully it'll be similar to
the way that the first one panned out
because
our technology the medium wouldn't have
happened and the volume which you know
all mandalorians filmed on and all these
different things now that wouldn't have
happened without James Cameron making
Avatar and and making Titanic before
that he's he's one of those people him
and George Lucas are two of those people
that are just
they don't put things out unless they
change the game in itself and I'm still
looking forward to how this one's going
to change the game don't know how yet
but I'm looking forward to finding out
well it's going to be a beautifully made
movie there's no argue with that it's
it's going to be beautifully made but
we'll see if it's any good
um and I'm saying I'm sure it will be
amazing I just don't think it'll be
three billion dollars amazing but we'll
see yeah another film I'm absolutely
looking forward to and then I actually
go every time I see the advert for it
Silent Night
I really really want to see it so good I
can't wait David Harbor is anything is
great David Harbor is a drunken Angry
Santa please just to know the story
about how this film got made right no
idea the director and the writer were
having a drinking they were getting
drunk basically and they were arguing
about whether Die Hard was a Christmas
movie or not
and um they'll obviously want to say yes
it is a Christmas movie it's a Christmas
for God's sake and then we go no it's
not an actual movie so they went right
we'll make a we'll make Die Hard a
Christmas movie we'll put Santa in it
and that story is probably true
probably it was enough yeah that's
probably how it happened
um but um I just I think I watched the
end of it and my inner child just goes
and there's a bit where he like it blows
somebody because I shouldn't watch I
shouldn't look ah got it
Eyes Wide Open just yeah oh man it's
just that yeah you're on my naughty list
naughty list or something I just I can't
wait I just I absolutely I just adore
them if the Phil makes a billion dollars
this Christmas I hope it's violent night
please
uh I think it's this weekend
the yeah
okay here it's next weekend I think so
um I can't wait
and it's such again it's the most stupid
storyline
um Santa Claus have you seen the start
Scrooged
have you ever seen that with Bill Murray
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
an actual bit in that when at the very
start it's one of the movies that's on
the on that Christmas and it's like
um and I can't remember what it's called
it's like Slade you know they do some
sort of put on the word slay or
something I can't remember but it was
basically terrorist attack Santa's
workshop and Lee may just turns up and
saves him he's got a midi gun
and kill some more and I'm like that was
a piss steak but that sort of they've
basically made that
except they've made Santa the hero and
was like this is the stupidest movie in
the world I cannot wait to watch it it's
just gonna be great I can't wait it's
gonna be amazing
um that really is the only two films
coming out this Christmas that even
remotely Tickle My Fancy there's
literally nothing else until mid-January
when Megan comes out and I'm quite
looking forward to watching Megan
that was creepy yeah a sci-fi horror
gotta love that
um but that really is the movie I think
it's it's crap
there is Pinocchio I I had to look up
all the movies coming out in December I
have my little list in front of me but
Guillermo del Toro's version of
Pinocchio is Guillermo del Toro that's
it's stop-motion Guillermo del Toro
oh that's perfect it it looks terrible
to me but what you never know
the Tom Hanks one right no no no no this
one's completely stop motion Tom Hanks
that one already came out and it was
awful nothing I avoided it like the
plague
um I I didn't know there's another one
coming out so there you go okay it's
from Guillermo del Toro himself so it's
going to be creepy and a lot more
so I generally I love what he does so
we'll have to see
Circle
I know Darren arvnowsky's the whale
comes out I think the eighth or ninth
it's gonna be mid-January in the UK but
um
well that looks excellent I I really
hope that does well
yeah there's really not too too much
besides those I think the the whale's
gonna be
um if he doesn't win an Oscar for that
there's something wrong with the world
um
but TV wise I tell you what Netflix is
the best if you if you are going to
subscribe to something this year
I think Netflix for one they've got
bullet train on and if you haven't seen
that's right
really annoyed it's on Netflix though in
a couple of weeks actually I think it's
like next week it starts on Netflix
because I just [ __ ] paid 10 pounds to
do the you know like the rental thing
because I wanted for my kids to watch it
because I thought they'd love it and so
I paid to rent it that's on Netflix in a
couple of weeks well you supported David
Leach he's very happy yeah exactly
um but uh Richard blood origin is coming
out on Netflix too which looks really
good yeah I'm looking forward to that as
well the glass onion knives that mystery
I really enjoyed footballers
um I do love though how they had to
release they did like an interview with
this producers confirmed that Daniel
Craig's character in Knives Out is gay
and I'm like yeah
that's not news really not relevant and
duh
does it even
though
apparently that had to be they had to
they had to announce that
um but yeah
the main thing that I'm looking forward
to this Christmas
Michelle yo hello
in the The Witcher blood origin yes
Christmas day comes out on Netflix
um and it looks bloody marvelous
yeah I generally can't I think that's
going to be the only decent Witcher
we're going to have after the third
series
um I was gonna ask you or just what do
you think about that in general just
because obviously it seems like Netflix
really wants to go forward with Witcher
things
but but can they after cattle's out they
should have just canceled it
that's kind of what I'm thinking for me
what they should have done they should
have canceled it gone with blood origin
maybe I don't know if blood Origins are
one-off series or
um gonna be a couple storm is back storm
is bad hello nice tanks it's it's a
problem with Chrome for me I don't know
what's on Chrome but I don't worry about
it too much
we're just talking about the The Witcher
blood origin series The premieres
Christmas Day I believe on Netflix
um uh right so Chris Hemsworth not Chris
Hemsworth his brother Liam is taking
over as
um The Witcher so yeah I was thinking
they should have just canceled it
gone with blood origin maybe and doing a
a another series Witcher related
told them they're going they should have
just ended The Witcher and started
another school with Liam Hemsworth it
can't
do you think they're just too far in do
you think that as The Witcher portion of
Netflix they think they're too far in
because they already have the prequel
series that and not series but the
preschool animated movies that I thought
was really well done and I I enjoyed
um and that's gonna be two series of
film and and maybe that that just
according to them that might feel like
they have too much to do something like
that I agree with you though where they
should just cut it off and
start something Anew but
I I guess I can see where their
producers might be thinking otherwise
yeah the the other thing is did the
production company already take cash
For That season and then without with uh
without knowing just assuming
that kaval was going to actually
continue with the park you know they may
have already taken yeah
contractual thing that they've got to do
x amount of Seasons you know it's like
uh
uh Amazon Prime has to do x amount of
seasons of
new Tolkien Series rings of power
because they've agreed in part of the
production
crazy like that you know maybe there's
marketing guys
yeah yeah nice forward planet
um Henry Cavill is never going to go
back and do more the Superman movies
they didn't they didn't see that coming
dumbasses
yeah so I mean yeah I I but I think
blood origin looks I honestly I think I
hate prequels you know if you ever if
you've ever mentioned me talk about
prequels before I hate them I think they
pistol over Canon and generally I don't
think they add anything to anything
um but this actually looks like it might
be quite good but I don't know why
they're doing a prequel why don't they
just do uh in Universe series with
Michelle yo and I would watch it because
I would watch anything right my God I
might actually love her
I have everything everywhere all at once
on in the background for Thanksgiving
for the whole family we all
it was great Michelle yeoh for
Thanksgiving every year
uh Michelle yo just in everything she's
just um I love I love her very much
um I I do I do regret that they're
pulling away from the um Star Trek
series from Australia the section 31
because that would have been [ __ ]
amazing but it's not gonna happen
um
but that's about it again that's about
it we've got the um Disney Plus
Disney plus I think has actually done
the best Christmas for me I'm quite
looking forward to a few things on there
you've got the Guardians the Galaxy
Christmas special have you seen it yet
no I'm holding off it's not Christmas
no it's already out
I know it's out but it's not Christmas
yet
oh okay
and so let's see the Coca-Cola out of
the holidays are coming it's not
Christmas
yeah it'll probably be out of the
theaters by the time Christmas gets here
yeah all right who wants that you know
another Marvel no my Christmas
decorations go up next weekend and then
I will watch the Guardians of the Galaxy
Christmas special
those are the rules
and then I probably should watch it and
then talk about it on the channel but
screw it
my Christmas it um I'll warn you it
takes a second to get into it it's it's
like slowly for the first 20 minutes 30
minutes does it happen is there
screaming goats
yeah that better not be oh dear God very
quickly if that makes sense
is it true that Amazon itself franchise
looks like talking about Netflix nope
move on
um
waiting for everything to boot I did not
know Jeffrey Combs was in Babylon 5.
he
plays Harriman Gray
Jeffrey Combs has been in every single
thing
he's been in everything good yeah
[Music]
amazing
um
right the other amazing looking thing on
Disney plus this year that I am looking
forward to Willow
looks amazing
I love that they've not tried to do like
a reboot or hard reboot they've actually
you know brought Warwick Davis back
they're doing a continuation of the
original story
um
yeah uh Harris is very blurry so I was
just going to comment Bob yeah
I guess it uh this is the internet I'm
not sure
maybe just everything sucks today you
know yeah yeah the internet sucks it's
cold but you know all you can do
Texas Wi-Fi rubbish
for a second come back or
see you in a second sir
you got him out of here yeah get out of
here
um
what do you think about the willow
though mate because I mean this film is
like what God it's gonna be 30 something
years old and it was the age
uh well I love the first one you know
and I especially like Val Kilmer in it
yeah and
um
what was his character's name mad
martigan yeah
it'll be interesting to see how they go
forth and see if there's any mention of
uh Morgan and if it's a central thing
and how they do that if they do that
yeah
they got to reference him there could be
you know
um
I'm glad they're not going to try to
chew horn him back into the story and
like use some CGI or something
apparently they're not apparently
they're not in it
um which I'm glad about but um it would
be a shame if they did that because it'd
be
I liked how they did it for topical
Maverick yeah it was really well done
yeah and it's nice that he was okay with
that to be honest because it was
obviously close to home yeah
um but um but no I think there were like
everything I've seen of Willow to be
honest it's it just looks like it's
going to be something that um
is similar to the original it's it you
know we will we will know what it feels
like and I can't believe Warwick Davis
looks to look so amazing he still looks
pretty odd he's gonna outlive us all
yeah he probably will yeah there's
another guy that's been in damn near
everything you know I mean yeah
didn't he play two roles in Harry Potter
they've definitely played wrong because
he point is it playing that Professor
flintric or something yeah and then he
played one of the I forget the name of
the goblin he played one of the Goblins
in the um thing aided so um Daniel
Radcliffe only played one part you know
I'm just saying Warwick guy
all this
yeah
um but yeah Mark Davis and Mike's just a
bit more work Davis hasn't changed a bit
and he needs
oh yeah but I know I think that's going
to be great that's one thing I will be
binging I've tried to get my kids to
watch it but I tried to get him to watch
the movie and my kids are 13 now they
sort of like about 20 minutes in they
were just like watch YouTube all right
yeah it's okay so I started watches
watch your YouTube
not even my videos
oh my gosh I'd be okay with that
smash a like on the video and if you're
new to the Channel please like And
subscribe but I know those subs nothing
nothing
um
how about you um Harris did you have you
ever watched Willow
oh yeah no I I've watched Willow and I
am
more than excited for a little more mad
again and some more with Davis
Warwick Davis anything I watch uh from
from An Idiot Abroad to Star Wars just
come on give me more Warwick
yeah yeah I don't know
I like how they've I've only we've only
seen hints of the story but it's all
going to be linked back in
um you know to the original yeah it's
going to be great look it up came out in
1988.
oh man I watch it Jesus Christ
34 years ago yeah yeah yeah I was 10
years old
[ __ ] brick I'll tell you what some of
the special effects look two years old
I was watching it
so I've forgotten about all the little
tiny Pixies or whatever oh the special
effects aren't right but I can see why
the movie costs so much money to make
and particularly with those little guys
and then there's some of the sets they
had
they had to make massive sets and tiny
little sets for them so I can see it
won't cost so much
um the only other thing I've got on my
list actually for Disney plus though is
the National Treasure series and that
with Catherine Zeta Jones and a few
others
I have no interest in that series at all
of you guys even have any interest in
that
all right
[Music]
um
uh the National Treasure series you know
the Nick Cage oh yeah the national
Treasury
uh
and I think Justin Barth is going to be
in there right yeah one of the original
guys
that's not the only Intrigue I have yeah
but I don't care even a little bit
which is a bit sad you know I'll I'll
watch the first two episodes you know
just to
just to see from us but you know
yeah so I just should give it a go but
Willow for just for a second just just
for a second
uh there was a movie that Willow
reminded me of came out a few years
earlier it was Dragon Slayer okay
awesome you know I re-watched it oh
about a month ago and the effects still
hold up I mean you know give that and
give a big round of applause to Sam
Winston for that I mean it was really
good
and the story was still tight you know
it still had those those um
medieval things and I think it was John
gilgood no yes no it wasn't it it was
just the acting was phenomenal now I
gotta look up it was John Gilbert who
played I'm gonna have to look it up as
well I also want to look up the film
what was the film it was
um Ralph Richardson I'm sorry Ron
Richardson
no not him not him oh and Ian McDermott
in himself
and of course it was starring um Caitlin
Clark and Peter McNeil
what was the film I thought it was Brian
Singer but apparently it's not
um it was like a cone on Style movie
with swords and stuff and wizards and
witches and things and that came out
about that time as well and I thought
the actor's name was Brian Singer but
it's not
because I've just looked it up no
director
there's something singing not the best
guy
Conan type movie to see what that pops
up with like that
no no no oh The Beastmaster
oh Bob Bob you are
awesome mate well done
um
m-a-r-c-s-i-n-g-e-r hmm Tanya Roberts
Rip Torn there he was in there ripped
home
he was great nobody ever plays Nutters
better than riptor
[Music]
um
yeah he has to look for Jeffrey Combs
he's probably an artist Janet Jones is
one of the witch women oh she's gorgeous
um one of the things I loved about I
tell you what I mean in the 80s I'd love
to do a video one of the days and just
do talk about some of the movies in the
80s because God it was a terrible decade
fashion and music and oh God it was
awful
um
hater aren't they from your neck of the
woods or oh no no but I tell you what
some of the greatest movies ever
what's wrong with you
anything about Billy Idol Cindy Whopper
are you a traitor that you didn't need a
Whopper
I'm a rock family they're best I've ever
came out in the 80s stop rock music in
the 80s was embarrassing the the one of
the best albums of the decade
all of a sudden
they're always I just love the fact that
stormy was excited about Sydney Lopper
and
[Music]
um
my uh my uh my cousin Tony stuck with me
my cousin Andrea she went off and
somehow got on the front row and just it
was a festival seating
and she just came back and just was
transformed oh my God Cindy I loved her
hair
oh
yeah
[ __ ] you I like that is an early 80s
were the best
and then all the different punks
iterations
um so I take that back Parts
clearly speaking it was God awful
um but I mean some of the greatest moves
generally some of the greatest movies
was the predator in the 80s
um
lady mid-80s was it
okay I'm gonna google it you know War
Games 80s Lost Boys Beetlejuice Legend
the first Batman
Breakfast Club Flash Dance
Commander oh yeah that was so sad Irene
Carey died the first June in her 60s
sure good come on Batman okay maybe not
Batman Labyrinth son big one in the 80s
Empire that won an Oscar talking Empire
that's not my favorite Spielberg
Yeah Christmas movie ever die hard came
out in the 80s yep that great smoothie
Goonies came out in the 80s the
Explorers that's bride what's wrong with
you came out in it I was one of the
greatest movies
this is what I'm saying the 80s was
terrible but the movies were bloody
brilliant
explorers with Ethan Hawke and River
Phoenix that is a great film
River Spaceballs Space Balls
and again Indiana Jones
it's just a barbarian Excalibur that was
actually good I like that I like to the
Navigator yeah another movie we've
mentioned before I don't know if you if
you're into anime or not but released
1986 aliens
Big Trouble in Little China yeah
the bedroom window
oh well I've just come across the
greatest movie ever made another Tim
Curry great classic movie clue what came
out there I love clue
um I think a telegram oh and in here
Howard the Duck
film's pretty bad
I love that when I was like oh it was
pretty bad
um and I can blow all of you at the
water villain Ted's most excellent
adventure
you know those those sit very specially
in my heart the Bill and Ted's I I love
they're excellent as they as they say
so and we're a Sci-Fi channel and we've
not mentioned
generally we've not mentioned Star Wars
Empire Strikes Back and Return of the
Jedi I'm a Star Wars fan I don't know
what you like talking about the butt to
the Future
forgot about that
um in a space how do I Shrunk the Kids
um
Ghostbusters
you said you were saving the best for
last right Jesus Christ yeah
um I'll tell you what some of the
greatest movies ever made were made in
the 80s we're gonna have to do a video
on it the original Batman yeah
Highlander's great
um
young man yeah I'm gonna have to take it
back it was just the fashion wasn't
great and um but I was a kid I was a kid
of the 90s really I was sort of
Cougar Mellencamp hey there you go
little John Cougar
in the 80s though I was generally
running around pretending to be a
helicopter
um you know it was like that was my
childhood and was like
um I didn't really wake up to anything
until the 90s kicked in so I shouldn't
really mention it but I was 12 in 1990
and that was when I sort of like
started listening to music and like I'll
go wrong some of the music in the 90s
was Bloody awful as well but we had
grunge and you know Nirvana and you know
Radiohead and YouTube John to a tree
come on
one of the greatest albums ever recorded
in the 80s
was that the 80s yes
Appetite for Destruction
we got Fleming games let's see I hate
that song synchronicity the police come
on it loves you he's rocked what's wrong
with you
the specials come on rookie Purple
Rain terrible song Thriller oh my God
Thriller
hate Prince
ah now you are going to get banned right
off the right out of
Peter Gabriel So
yeah I did like
Peter Gabriel or Phil Collins
Pretty Hate Machine
I love the story about how Phil Collins
got that gig and
like give Peter Gabriel left and they
were like um rehearsing and they were
getting people into like in you know
interview whatever for the singer and
they kept going okay sing it like this
and Peter you know and Phil Collins had
sing it and then they tried to get the
singer to sing it and after about the
fifth or sixth interview they realized
Phil Collins is better than all of them
so they just promoted Phil
come on now
yeah great Brothers in Arms
that is a album for the century come on
yeah that was a good album I had a great
video as well to be fair Private Dancer
what's wrong with you the 80s were great
no if they weren't but it'll be on the
Stars
the spaceship that looked like they've
had massive testicles
um
chance to cross the sands
I'll tell you what I've just I'm not
gonna have to take it back because I've
just looked at the best 1980s comedies
right Uncle book
Gremlins
The Great Outdoors
action movies Top Gun Commando Blue
Thunder Beverly Hills Cop
um
Nicholson one of his most iconic roles
was the 80s The Shining the shiny that's
1980 itself yeah
1980 sci-fi
Blade Runner yeah Tron the last star
fighter yeah oh man there's some great
movies there aliens robot cop
yeah people were telling us how shitty
the 80s were so we've already been there
and then
they live lady Roddy Piper
it's a great film
we did you did mention fashion sucks so
there it goes your writers
um
rain man I've got the 80s erase really
man
born on the fourth of July oh Jesus
Christ there's a lot of good films in
the 80s I did start by saying there was
some amazing movies in the 80s Arthur
overboard
Elvira Mr of Darkness
oh God I love that
Scrooge which I mentioned earlier
oh God it went on and on and on it was
amazing I take it back to the 80s race
yeah
if we're looking at TV shows you know
MacGyver came out in the 80s oh yeah the
18.
Star Trek next Generation came out in
the 80s
I came out in the 80s my God is barely
look at me that was uh oh Schnucks I'd
have been I didn't mean to get into it
until like the third series or so I had
to go back and watch it so that would be
about right one of the best underrated
comedies of the 80s was Night Court
oh knife works great the TV show yeah
yeah yeah over here
I don't remember Nightcore and if you go
what look up uh um
oh um the perform I'm trying to think
what the character's name was but Brett
speier had this hillbilly character in
night court and he killed as a comedian
I mean he killed it it's on YouTube Just
Brent Spiner Night Court oh my God he
nailed it
um if data was only a hillbilly we would
have a slapstick Enterprise it would
have been I mean let's go to YouTube
look it up he killed it
oh yeah yeah okay I'm with you on that
and the Star Wars Christmas Special that
would have been the 80s wouldn't it
it would have been yeah late 70s
Knight Rider 18 Miami The Golden Girls
why are you hating on the gold anymore
what did they ever have to do to you
treasure but we're not doing it Betty
White it was a National Treasure but
only when she had the chains and she was
able to swear
she wasn't
Harris I think you do you have to run
instead because I think you've got a
plane to catch haven't you
probably the next three or four minutes
okay cool
um uh I want to ask you a cheers was
done in the 80s right Jordan started in
the 80s didn't it or was it like 90 92
I still watched it do you know what was
great about that started in the 80s I
think 88-ish
well I mean oh alienation movie and
series was phenomenal it was great
serious
um the series was better than the movie
I thought
um
the the thing about the 80s and the 90s
I think was that all the theme music and
stuff was just so much better than
nowadays
you know
um how many times would you mark
remember
um how many times did you like you know
there's that old joke isn't it about how
uh my mum says photos can't sing and
then they have a picture of Airwolf or
the A-Team or something and then you had
immediately
you know or all the 18 things the theme
Tunes back in the day were just amazing
they're [ __ ] nowadays they're not
they don't put the effort in you mean
they had heart and soul before it just
was reboot and rehash and and try to
just redo a little bit of something
that's already been done before that's a
bit cynical house
the Youth of today
well see I mean I was about to say the
the only good theme song I can think of
in recent memory is Game of Thrones and
although House of dragons awesome
they just reused the same damn theme
they were like it's successful let's
keep moving with it and I remember uh
movies horror movies that we have now
seen 20 franchise 20 sequels from oh
yeah that was all the 80s Nightmare on
Elm Street you know Halloween
Hellraiser 13th Evil Dead
ah
Day of the Dead
I've never heard of this one Cannibal
Holocaust that should have been our show
let's see what I mean Cannonball Run
how'd you just get about coming back
the Bandit movies I love smoking the
Bandit I have a great films Reynolds
dead sewer the Iron Man if you've never
watched tetsuo the Iron Man it was like
this cultish Japanese black and white
kind of a lot of stop-motion
tetsuo
t-e-t-s-u-o the Iron Man not body Hammer
don't give me this body Hammer crap
ghosty tattoo of the Iron Man watch it
once
make sure the volume is up and but make
sure
seriously 1986 is five-ish tetsuo the
Iron Man
okay just thinking first of all my first
thought then was I mentioned Cannonball
Run a second ago are we gonna watch
Cannonball Run or is it racist sexist
misogynistic and everything else
or am I allowed to watch it are we even
allowed to watch airplane anymore like
Blazing Saddles get old yeah I mean oh
my God
Richard Pryor wrote it so I guess we can
still watch it yeah
I mean it's like that's the whole point
of it it's like yeah
um oh it's just so funny it's it's just
brilliant the only problem with Blazing
Saddles is they've run out of money at
the end and then they've got the whole
end scene which basically because they
just ran out of money you just have to
film
Amazing subtle oh I love that yeah and
then
oh some of the martial art movies in the
80s
it's just yeah oh midnight run midnight
run it's just that again that's a great
movie
um oh the best Robert De Niro films
we're in the 80s
so
um in the 90s too though he just had a
hit a lot in the 90s that were great
especially that Park in the 90s as well
um but you're right Friday 13th yep all
right well I might have to bow out real
quick I will see you all in a week and
and I'll have all my 90s films thought
of by then don't worry it's uh Stargate
next week next week
good you know I'm ready for Stargate
I'll be all the way through season eight
and all the way through season one I'll
have to get an SGA shirt now yeah uh
okay
it's a case appropriate it's the correct
gate now which is actually this SGU
propagate SGA propagate sg1 propagate
because I forgot to do that initially
when I made those t-shirts
but I've done it
Harris thank you very much sir as always
we will see you hear us soon
go then
it takes so long just to talk about milk
in it
um how many films do you think actually
then right started in the 80s and then
they're still making no well I mean
which uh which
um I've lost track of the number of
Indiana Jones is five or six coming out
it's the fifth one isn't it and it's got
it it's well I put it this way it can't
be worse than Crystal Skull
so they've always got that going it
can't be worse than Crystal Skull it
can't answer size of [ __ ] dogs what
was that about
um
everything about that movie and that
could keep up with the driving like 60
miles an hour and the answer of keeping
up right yeah
actually staying you know the the how
the Jeep survived the water falls plural
there was lots about that movie that you
have to sit and go what the what were
they smoking when they thought that was
a good idea I knew it was bad when
Harrison Ford tumbled out of the
refrigerator
yeah surviving the nuclear explosion
yeah
the door just pops open
because we all know that right yeah
they're like oh man really that just
happened yeah no they did that and they
weren't they weren't they weren't even
they didn't even apologize
thing about the original one was they
really took the subject matter seriously
it was still funny in places and I still
have little jokes there's no humor but
it was it took the subject matter
seriously but there's like ants and
I just think geriatric Indiana Jones is
going to be a problem he can barely move
so I'm not sure how they're going to do
it
um but I don't know they threw him back
into Star Wars and that kind of worked
so
Maybe
but that was nearly 10 years ago now
he's 10 years older than that now
I don't know I think Harrison Ford they
must have just driven literally driven
up to his front door with a dump truck
full of money and just dumped it please
make another Indiana Jones film and he
said they're wrong like Scrooge McDuck
swimming
oh okay then here's enough money for
your next airplane here you go yeah we
will buy you a 737
um
as we missed you we'll just have another
five minutes before we head off for the
evening but as we missed you so much
last week where we were talking about
what we loved the most in 2022 but you
were busy working
um building spaceships was there
anything that you wanted to add to the
just the discussion like that you really
adored because you know what we didn't
mention rings of power once
see I got to be here to represent God
some of the things I really enjoyed I
discovered in 2022 I didn't know they
didn't uh want weren't released
um I still think penny worth it's in
like season three now or something
really really excellent we were
discussing um
the failures of DC Universe is one of
The Shining lights really it's just it's
still didn't say TV BT Bank good TV yeah
they're a terrible movies but they make
good TV yeah I don't understand that you
know it's
uh yeah anyway pennyworth was one of
those and of course you know um
rings of power
what was I don't we we never mentioned
that did we that was that that Lord of
the Rings thing Amazon did the Rings
thing I thought that was going to be
controversial when it came out
yeah barely know I spoke about it all
right let's don't let's throw in indoor
was excellent okay I thought andal
really ended off the year really well
actually I thought that was fantastic uh
was it really hip on love and thunder
that was terrible
I did like uh Maverick too
do you know why that was good though
clever I love that airplane yeah they
just yeah they just they didn't try to
be clever they just did right got Top
Gun we have Jets and we had a bad guy
that was from an undescript country so
which country is that from fifth
generation Fighters but from what
country generation Fighters but what
country are they actually fighting
generation Fighters they were terrorists
the fifth generation Fighters how does
that even yeah exactly
um if you haven't seen it go and look at
it have you ever seen that cartoon
series how it should have ended
um
[Music]
it's actually very funny okay
and it points out some quite big gaping
holes in the in the plot but like I said
they didn't try to be clever they just
did
a movie they didn't try and do anything
to to you know
that we know we'd love and then it made
one and a half billion dollars at the
box office postcode if that's just
stupid money
um another thing I liked is
um
uh Strange New World I think
when we talked about doing the video
last week we said what surprised us the
most yes and I think Peacemaker was for
me I love Peacemaker Harris hated it I
love Peacemaker
um and for me Strange New World yeah
Peacemaker with uh eagley right is this
the one we're talking about we're not
talking about the uh no eagerly that's
the the uh Suicide Squad yeah see
Suicide Squad was awful
it was so bad it made me want to put my
mind bits in a blender and turn it on
yeah
um uh it was it was so bad
um but then so when Peacemaker came out
I remember I saw it just happened on
YouTube I just saw the starting sequence
where they come dancing and I thought oh
I'm gonna have to watch that oh yeah you
gotta watch that and it was brilliant
but again DC make good TV they just make
terrible terrible movies they do it's uh
you know and it's sad because there's so
much such Rich material there yeah
there's one thing I didn't start off
when it premiered in
a year but it's one of the things we
really can't quote from and that's the
boys
now you can't quote any of it's because
you're happy in the past
I did once and you beat me up but yeah
that wasn't yeah I would have flown to
America just
and then float home
it was really good I really you know I
mean talk about a study and cycle it's
like a lot bad psychological Behavior
boys was really hit I like that I I like
boys because it's so clever when they do
a lot of superhero movies they always do
good versus bad white hats versus black
hats right yeah and in in in comic books
that's right and a lot of like obviously
Fringe Comics books it's not like that
but that's generally Marvel Marvel have
actually been quite good with the bad
guys because like they're bad guys are
sort of gray like Thanos was not really
a bad guy oh he didn't he didn't think
he was anyway
um and like from Daredevil the Kingpin
he didn't think he was a bad guy he
thought he was just making tough
decisions
um for the greater good sort of thing
um but in the boys I just love that if
you go give any normal person
superpowers they will turn into absolute
c words what I like to say yeah
um and that's just aside that's why I
love it I'm just thinking yeah of course
they'd be greedy and corrupt and you
know even crazy yeah
um
foreign
it's kind of it's really alternative
history it's not really sci-fi or it's
kind of horror Maybe
uh well is and sometimes really
difficult
it was handmaid's tale this year it was
really good Elizabeth Moss is hitting on
Austin she's a great actress isn't she
a great writer great producer great
director I mean
this is probably this last season
probably the best and you can tell her
fingerprints are all over she's an
amazing amazing
yeah and you know especially this last
year in America Henry's tells especially
poignant
[Music]
um
yeah I know yeah and I I've only watched
this season and watched the first two
seasons but I watched this season on
your recommendation actually basically
saying you have to watch it or else so I
did yeah it was and it's one of those
shows as well then a few points really
sort of makes you go
I need to pause that and think about it
for a second and I don't normally like
that sort of thing I normally like
popcorn mouth right right
um but when a when a TV show makes you
think
there's another book
probably from the 80
. that should have always probably been
a TV series or at least a movie it was
called Fatherland there was another
um yes I remember the alternative
history about you know what would happen
if we come if the uh allies had come to
some sort of uh truce
and uh in terms of how it was like
discussing the decay of the Third Reich
and the the hyper rise
another alternative series and the same
thing was made in a high castle which
yeah but I watched that since that show
didn't it but it was a great series
great series great series
I can't believe you've not mentioned Sun
man
I'm getting around to it I'm gonna do it
quicker yeah
it is um
coming out for a second season I mean
it's just
I've got did I show you my Sandman comic
books that I did did we get to this
point yet I love how they're always
and let me just show off oh
Sandman
volume one it's a bit of a thick read
and it's like all comic books which is
not too beautiful
um
oh my God it's so heavy
yeah
those are beautiful ones oh yeah with
the black Edge papers yeah so it's
don't you fret
when you do your will can you put can I
have to you just don't know what you're
okay I think
if you if you don't mind I don't want
anything else
um
and a piece of your one of the
spaceships if you could just make me a
nut or something that would be great
you'd be astonished how well we track
[ __ ] that doesn't go on
yeah I no my I I I have half an idea how
much these things cost I imagine that
yes you do track bits and Bobs very
closely even with just crap it's just
like where's that gone yeah well it's
just like Nick and [ __ ] it's like then
the wing falls off the nut from the wing
annoying who's got that what's wrong
with it I'm sorry
um mate I'm so glad you're back me too
uh I couldn't speak to that young
American anymore
I think it was last week and we kept
talking about
um our different TV series and films
tonight guys have you seen blah blah and
both of them were like no [ __ ] where's
stormy stormy will have watched it
stories probably taking notes
because I'm a miss storm
um but no thank you so much mate and uh
no so next week we are doing our
Stargate Sunday because it's the first
of the month yeah the week after that
I'm in New York so there may not be a
video that week unless Matt France is
doing something but um but yeah I'm in
New York so I can't really do a video in
New York
why am I going to New York or it's my
wedding anniversary so
um I'm taking the wife to I'm going to
New York for your wedding anniversified
someplace romantic we want to see we
want to see the city at night and you
know go to um go see the Christmas trees
oh the Christmas tree yeah but that's
where we went to my honeymoon so we're
going
so first time that we did New York we
did on your honeymoon oh my God
always wanted to go we love their tooth
fairy we just wandered around Central
Parking hot dogs
I've um I just I've paid for and it was
God it was expensive but don't tell her
because she doesn't know so I should
probably shouldn't sell it publicly but
she doesn't watch these videos anyway
um
carriage ride around Central Park oh
there's yeah okay they're not cheap at
Christmas
340 oh my God now I hate New York even
more it's 60 the rest of the time in the
rest of the year I suppose they've got
you yeah
um four feet of snow on the ground I
hope it snows that would be amazing
um at the moment it looks like it's
gonna be about 15 degrees outside
and we're doing a cruise a dinner cruise
on the um on one of the rivers going up
the Brooklyn
so that'd be nice and she doesn't know
either of those and then we're going up
um we will be going up the Rockefeller
to see the city
looking forward to that and we're gonna
go see like an ice hockey game and a few
other things so it's cool Madison Square
Garden so
um I might try to cheekily do a video or
two from New York but only if the wife
gets distracted by something shiny
um here's a couple of good Dave go buy
something shiny from Macy's and then
I'll do a video wondering if something
happens now in my luck Amazon announced
Stargate while I'm away
yeah yeah
after 12 months you know what you could
do you could pre-record a Stargate
amazing news and you know Amazon you
know is starting a newspaper here's why
we know and just make up [ __ ] and
then just you know have it ready to go
you know you still get the clicks even
though you're probably horrifically yeah
I'll just do a video saying Stargate has
been announced Stargate hasn't been
announced and then edit both the signs
and just release either you know like
I'm on the moon landings they had both
headlines ready just in case in case
I'll do that I'll do that there has been
some interesting
um Amazon news and I'll tell all the
stargaters watching the series are
watching that moment just keep looking
for all these stories that have suddenly
started appearing
that mentioned Stargate there was
another one today and a lot of them are
do you remember that franchise that
nobody watched and they're going we all
we all watched it like everybody our age
watched it April how many deck for a
decade you know I mean surely somebody
watched it it was yeah it was the
highest gross in um premiere on the on
the Showcase it was the hyper it was
mgm's second highest gross in um
franchise
we all watched it but all of these
stores and I told you guys over a year
ago these stores will start to appear
then they have so I'm excited it's kind
of like gate world I mean it's just it
it is just bits and pieces of the next
series what's you know what's what's it
going to be about gay world can't shut
up about it you know yeah well I'm not a
big fan of gate well because gate will
have been slagging me off so oh well
[ __ ]
this yeah [ __ ] you gay wolf so you know
if you are a side tracker unsubscribe
from Gateway
um yeah they've been slagging me off and
um it's just a little bit of a jealousy
and but I did a little [ __ ] comment
about how when Brad Wright did some
tweets I did a video the next day and
and Stargate did a video a week later
saying about how Brad rice tweeted about
no that his script is dead I'm like and
I did leave believe it but you've always
this took a week
but I I got a message back so I didn't
talk to him occasionally but a couple of
the subscribers
um talk to them regularly in there
they've been slagging me off so they can
[ __ ] off
um
yeah yeah no they love you
um but when stagger gets announced if
please God
um uh I'm gonna do a really really Petty
and no no no no no I Told You So video
and it's gonna be
painful to watch for everybody else but
I am going to [ __ ] love it it's your
Vindication yes exactly I'm just gonna
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no exactly
um like
thank you so much
um I'm so glad you're
um back and not working ridiculous hours
oh my God
next time I'll go to Canada I think I'm
supposed to say New York sucks
um the first time around what I did was
I took her to New York and then we went
to Niagara Falls and did proper like
honeymooning yeah but we went to the
Canadian side
oh which is much better
the American side sucks
um but we had we stayed at this hill to
the the
um the the is it the shell Shelton or
something I've got a new Motel now but
it's literally right in front of the
falls
so like the Sheridan Sheridan hey
oh I gotta discuss something with you
once we're wrapped up here don't okay
then well let's call it awesome lovely
evening guys everyone watching thank you
so much we will see you next week
Sunday special episode we don't know
what it's about yet except other than
Stargate but we'll see
say bye-bye stormy goodbye stormy
take care see ya
be good and if you can't be good be
careful be careful
[Music]